every Tuesday on ion money series we'll
look at financial issues Americans are
facing this morning we're focusing on
college debt almost two million
Americans will graduate this year with a
bachelor's degree 70% of them will be in
debt and they'll have an average loan
debt of more than $33,000 according to a
2018 survey parents are the number one
source of payments for an undergraduate
degree CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with what college
grads and their families need to
prioritize Jill good morning a lot of
people wrestling with this right now as
their graduates are coming home what do
you body prioritize I think the first
thing you have to do is start tracking
your money so encourage your kids to get
one of these apps and there are lots of
free ones there free ones from banks
there's mint.com there's clarity money
find out what's coming in what's going
out now you're gonna build in that
student loan debt and you really want to
try to figure out how many loans do you
have outstanding what is actually the
interest rate of each of those loans and
while those companies are gonna give you
the minimum that's do you want to pay
more than the minimum the only way you
can figure out how much more is to track
that money going in and out so these
students who have debt on average if
they have it they're paying about $400 a
month on those loans you tell people to
save but they also have the loans how do
they deal with the loans and save at the
same time what are they do first welcome
to adulthood where multiple priorities
struggling with it my whole life
it's very so I always talked about
something called the big three and what
are the big three it's paying down debt
it's having an emergency reserve fund
and it's starting that great habit of
retirement savings the problem is that
one is not necessarily more important
than the other we sort of have yes to
all of them if you've got large
outstanding student loans you want to
put a little bit more extra money down
on those loans if you can but on the
other hand if you've got a company that
has a matching component to your
retirement plan you want to at least put
a little bit of money there so a little
bit of everything but only those three
things are the things that new grads
need to concentrate on well the numbers
show that a lot of kids are going to
their parents perhaps the emergency fund
yeah
it's a pretty good emergency fun too
seven out of ten have gone to their
parents for help a lot of adults are
dipping into their retirement funds to
help their kids good idea bad idea
I'm really worried about a lot of
parents now look if you are an extremely
fortunate family and your parents can
help you out okay that may work but for
so many families parents are
shortchanging their own retirement and
this is dangerous and the reason is that
when your kids have these loans and
they're paying off their loans that's
fine if later on you can help them after
you've got a secure retirement that's
one thing but if you cannot retire with
great security you're gonna have to turn
to your kids to help bail you out and as
you said to me in the green room I hope
they're there for you I hope it's not
you help Mom last time now it's your I
did it last time now to your dad I don't
know is an adult parent how you don't
help your kids I want to say this you
want to assist and guide but not to
enable all right got it
that is good very like that what does it
slow thank you Joe